it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online
[Music]
Madonna confirmed she adopted twin girls
from Malawi earlier this month and it
seems the little ones are following in
their mama's fashionable footsteps check
out their adorable matching PJ's Jimmy
Kimmel proved he's a pretty awesome and
artistic dad the late night host got
creative with his daughter James
breakfast and turned an ordinary pancake
into dory Wow John Legend squeezed in
some quality time prepping for the
Oscars with his daughter Luna of course
at the piano and speaking of kids
there's no denying Candace Cameron Bure
was a cute one she posted this throwback
of her first head shot when she was just
five years old shortly before landing
her gig on full house as DJ Tanner and
over on YouTube BBC Radio 1 shared this
hilarious clip of Ed Sheeran crashing
Katy Perry's interview thanks for
keeping me off the number one spot
thanks oh you're so approachable
oh you're everybody's best friend
nothing like a little friendly
competition
you